20 years ago the world escape the  clutches of extinction we must never  forget our survival is only possible  when we stand together we have found  strength and unity as a planet and that  strength has brought us the power to  survive and the world was brought to its  knees the army was there to fight back  promised us that this would never happen  again they have been the driving force  in uniting nations around the world to  form the most powerful weapon against  another attack the earth space defense  brave men and women of the ESD are  making sure that the war of 96 will  never happen again  join earth space defense next time we  will be prepared